[Music]
[Applause]
yeah happy Monday control yourself put
your pants back
on so let's talk about January 6 I know
I know but was it really as our
mainstream media contends 911 and Pearl
Harbor rolled into one well thanks to
the new house Speaker Mike Johnson video
from inside the Capitol building was
just released almost 3 years later
showing what many who attended the
protest have been contending all along
that not only were the Capital Doors
more open than Hunter nose on a Saturday
night but in many cases the Capitol
Police either escorted the protesters in
like ushers at a wedding or stood by
without objecting now let's be clear no
one's defending the chaos on the capital
so spare me the Gutfeld supports
Insurrection tweets from substitute
teachers in Brooklyn still traumatized
by Trump slapping Hillary into
retirement
I may not support riots but I do support
the truth and we have the right to hear
the whole story especially when many of
the protesters were veterans and average
citizens who just wanted their voices
heard and who've been prosecuted like
they were Hamas actually worse than if
they were Hamas because no one's
defending the Jan Sixers on campus just
look at who was selected for the
so-called select committee you couldn't
get a worse roster if you combin CNN's
lineup with the cast as Saved by the
Bell
usually to get that kind of Kangaroo
Court you'd have to hop on a flight on
quantis that's an Australian uh
Airline ah there you go there you go
what's now clear is that any video that
didn't fit the committee's narrative was
ditched like one of Joe Biden's
grandkids so who exactly was on this
so-called bipartisan select committee
well on the Democrat side well it
doesn't matter the faces changed but the
lock step SL Goose step Remains the Same
one of them is house Dam Jamie Rasin
who's already complaining about the
released
footage beyond the the partisan nature
of it it's truly a security risk what
they're doing the reason why the capol
police have opposed releasing tens of
thousands of hours from every house
office building every Senate Office
Building every part of the capital is
because it's like a diagram to Future
insurrectionists and terrorists and
anybody who wants to invade our
body I think he's full
of I wonder if he knows you can take a
tour and see most of the capital if you
want to and most committee hearings are
open to the public but the chances of
the Dems giving conservative protesters
and Veterans a fair Shake are roughly
equivalent to Jesse Waters giving his
hair stylist the day
off and any committee formed to uncover
truth that includes Adam Schiff is like
making Ted Bundy the head of Visiting
Angels that would be a bad
choice the committee claimed to be
bipartisan because it included
Republicans Liz Cheney and Adam kininger
and I'll admit it was good to have women
representative from the Republican side
but did we need to oh sexist would
say kiner cried more times during those
hearings than a Kardashian at an onion
eating
contest the puddles below Adam's desk
were so large the hearings should have
had a lifeguard on duty but Kinser got
what he wanted of course a job kissing
up to dams over at CNN where they're
used to seeing grown men cry especially
when the ratings come in hey Adam maybe
shoot a bit higher next time I hear
Media Matters needs a
janitor then there's Liz Cheney who
reportedly still has political
aspirations she just needs to bump her
liability numbers up a bit right now she
ranks just above Jerry sanduski and just
below
[Laughter]
Isis so Liz Adam let's review some of
the great work from you and the Biden
doj here's new video of Matthew Perna a
man who had no criminal record
whatsoever walking calmly into the
capital that day now I don't know what
happened outside before but clearly the
police are not concerned or even
directing the protesters to leave perno
was initially charged with trespass a
charge he reportedly accepted but when
the Department of Justice decided to add
a terrorism enhancement it was more than
he could take Matthew Perna took his own
life here's another new video of police
releasing a protester you don't see too
many terrorists that fist bump do you
except for Hamas they do that after they
kill innocent children and they're still
the toast of the ivy league so Matthew
Perna gets a terrorism enhancement which
adds years to a sentence while the
antifa Thugs who destroyed a police
station in Seattle attacked a federal
courthouse and shut down cities while
pretending to care about the
Palestinians they aren't even
investigated you can even attack
Democratic National headquarters as long
as you're anti-trump meanwhile literally
hundreds of January 6 protesters are
looking at decades in jail and it's
Trump that this select committee
referred for prosecution for mean
tweeting now one of the first ways you
know you're on to something is when the
Legacy Media starts to sing in unison
like the Beach Boys on
autotune here's just a few headlines
since the full videos came out notice
the repetition conspiracy theories
disinformation and never Republican it's
always far right that's how you know
we're over the target it's the hysteria
because to the left these days we're the
terrorists and Hamas is the political
party now let me say it again so even
the half wits on The View get it I don't
support attacking the Capitol Building
I've seen those same three January 6
videos the committee and the mainstream
media wanted us to see over and over a
thousand times and it's cut together so
well it was up for an Oscar in the
category of best
editing but I've also seen a few other
things from the same sources like the
crossfire hurricane conspiracy thanks to
two other CNN contributors Peter stro
and Andrew McCabe you won't find two
bigger dildos at an adult toy
store
by the way you can't say dildo it's a
medical
term and of course there was the
dismissal of the laptop from hell as
Russian propaganda and there's the four
criminal cases against Trump that
wouldn't have been brought against any
other living Soul or even a dead one
like Nancy
Pelosi and yes these new January 6
videos that contradict everything the
select committee told us sadly it's too
late for Matthew Perna but maybe it's
not too late to recognize that some
other people from the capital that day
need to be investigated and I'm not
talking about protesters let's just say
a certain select group and if the
Republicans have a big day next November
it could be all over but the
crying let's
welcome tonight's guest ironically he
moved from DC to a farm to deal with
less crap news contributor Charlie
her looks charm intelligence all things
she's complimented me for having host of
The Hoop chat Emily
Austin he's got the voice of an Angel if
that angel smoked marble Reds for 30
years comedian Jim
Florentine and finally she has a
full-time intern just to clean her
glasses host of Kennedy Saves the World
podcast
Kennedy all right Charlie it's not just
a Farm by the way it's not just I'm I'm
literally right across the street from a
dairy and do you know how much cow crap
gets created by a dairy no it's amazing
it's a lot but I still roll the window
down when I get close because it smells
so much better than DC no that just
says I was gonna say that just means
that the inside of your car smells
really bad
well and it's also less than you get on
the street walking around New York that
is true and there's no cattle here not
San Francisco though yeah no very bad
what do you make of this latest release
videos are you surprised did you learn
anything uh well well yeah I mean at
first I thought that the reason
Democrats were so upset about the the
video being released is I thought they
were just trying to like trying to uh
you know because nobody cares about this
this is not a political issue that's
going to work in in an election and so I
thought maybe they were trying to like
trying to protect pretend like there was
something secret about all this stuff
but now I think when you look at the
video miles and miles of video where
people are not doing anything and the
biggest lie is what you pointed out
nobody supported this there's not a
single person at Fox or in any sort of
and I hang out with some real
right-wingers I'm a real like even my
dad you don't get more right-wing than
my dad my dad's like this is disgusting
this is terrible we should be nobody but
but they is he still hiding in Argentina
they so they so so they so they have to
build this lie that there are all these
people who are like supporting this
stuff and then but it turns out that
actually what it is it's a bunch of old
grandmas and you know people that were
are upset about their country and upset
about their government and think that
the election was was stolen yeah I mean
Emily if that was an attempted coup
that's like the most polite attempted
coup I've ever seen imagine though like
if four I think there were four people
from January that among the protesters
that committed suicide if that were the
a BL BLM uh protest or even these Pro
Palestinian Hamas uh people that had
committed suicide there would be
monuments everywhere instead we don't
even know their names no they're they're
Freedom Fighters Greg and that's the
problem America is preaching we are
serving Justice by trying these people
who apparently were very peaceful but
they strategically did not show us that
part of the media and instead right now
you mentioned BLM they burnt down
businesses to the ground they robbed and
Gucci in the name of black lives we have
pramas groups that are barricading the
borders of the White House that are
throwing blood there putting free Gaza
on police cars shadowing wind uh
shattering windows and vandalizing and
killing people in LA and I haven't heard
the Outreach they put a a cafe on
Benjamin Franklin's head they ripped
down statues and it's true though they
ripped down American flags all over
Manhattan where's the outrage where is
the Justice now America how come we are
very selective on something that
happened 3 years ago and right now
they're destroying our own country as we
speak no outrage there
yeah yeah when I saw Ben Franklin with a
cafe on he looked a lot like um Fidel
Castro Fidel
Castro yeah you know Jim I'm going to
read you a question that was written to
written by one of my writers okay Jim
what do you think is the worse event
January 6 or one of your standup shows
you sure that wasn't my agent that wrote
that is this some just another coverup
it is and it's also that's a lot of
footage to be putting out there 40,000
hours yeah you know at least can you
break it up in like a 10-part Netflix
series so I can watch it slowly you know
what I mean that's going to be a lot of
boring stuff 40,000 hours that is a you
point out though kind of an interesting
difference that the Democrats know how
to put on a show they like they they
they curated it put it together and and
knew everybody was going to watch it all
the networks were going to take it and
then what we do is we just release all
of it and it just like kind of like
dilutes yeah that's like a Tarantino's
our director you let it go 40,000 hours
like his movies you know um they should
have put at least put like a bloopers
reel
out like someone that made a mistake and
went to the linoln memorial
instead you know someone maybe they ma
themselves I like to
like that but or maybe put like a cool
soundtrack behind the 40,000 hours like
some cool music yeah have like I don't
know you know uh somebody narrate it
that'd be cool yeah like who it should
be you actually with your voice I would
do that or Morgan Freeman yes people
always say that about my voice if he's
doing voiceovers or Holly I go until
Morgan Freeman dies I got no shot that's
everything so I'm just waiting you're
just waiting slowly patiently Kennedy
how are you hi yeah does this infuriate
you it kind of kind of bugs me because I
know that there's nothing that can be
done and there are people we actually
have political prisoners in America
right now and we go on with our lives
yeah we have political prisoners in
Russia and people go on with their lives
journalists and and no one seems to care
but yeah to Emily's Point like all this
stuff is happening here yet we reserve
words like Insurrection for a group of
people that we're politically opposed to
and that's how you know a hyper
Poitier for everybody because you are
creating a climate where you could be
imprisoned essentially without due
process because someone doesn't like
your ideas but what they never consider
is well what happens if the pendulum
swings and the people I hate are in
charge and now they don't like my ideas
well guess what they can throw you in
prison just as easily and it will happen
in this country because our sense of
justice is so skewed and it is so
incredibly out of control and imbalanced
and you know it's like I watch those
protests ERS walk up to the White House
and put their little bloody palm prints
on everything and I was like
Insurrection yeah where's Adam kiner in
his tears now yeah all right hey Sean
Hannity here hey click here to subscribe
to Fox News YouTube page and catch our
hottest interviews and most compelling
analysis you will not get it anywhere
else